للنساء العزبات لا تحزن من تاخر الزواج
رساله وجهها داعيه الكويتيه والمستشار
الاسري مؤخرا واثاره الكثيره من الجدل حيث
قال انه لا توجد امراه عانسب الامراه
حفظها الله من شر زواج سيء هذه تصريحات
اثار التساؤلات اي النساء اسعد المتزوجات
ام العاذبات خاصه
عن الزواج سنه بعد سنه وارتفاع معدل سن
الزواج لدى الفتيات الى الثلاثينات
وارتفاعها لسه بالطلاق في المجتمعات
العربيه
وبين المشاكل والعلاقات الزوجيه غير
الناجحه هل يعتبر الزواج نعمه للفتيات ام
نقمه في عصرنا الحالي
والله انا رايي ان انا متفقه جدا
العروسه المفروض ما يبقاش اسمها عروسه
يعني العروسه دي اختيار
كويس جدا احسن مختار جواز فاشل ينتج عنه
ابناء يتربى في الظروف قاسيه او الام
تتحمل مسؤوليه كامله في ظل قوانين ما بقتش
بتساعد المراه بشكل قوي انها تاخذ
مصاريف لاولادها كويسه بعد الطلاق تسمح
لها انها تقدر تعيشهم كويس او تعلمهم كويس
فنتج عن الجواز الخطا لما بينتج عنه اسره
تدمرت واولاد مستقبلهم بقى مجهول وبقى
مبهم فطبعا انا من انصار ان العنوسه او ما
اسمهاش علوسه هي البنت من غير جواز مش همم
مش بتختار ده مش اختيار سيء ده دي انسان
اختارت راحتها ونجاحها حريتها بدل ما تضيع
حياتها وتتمنى الموت في جواز ما كانش ينفع
انها تكمل فيه رشه لما تقول البنت اختارت
همم
وحريتها يعني كمان لا ينطبق على كل
الزيجات يعني قد تكون المراه متزوجه
ولديها الراحه الكافيه ولديها ايضا الحريه
الكافيه احنا بنتكلم على نسبه كبيره للاسف
فيها مجتمع بشكل مجتمعي مش بشكل اا اي مع
المشاعر وقايم على الاختيار الحر للاسف
يعني حضرتك بتتكلمي كما لو كانت هي اختارت
اختيار حر احنا بنتكلم على الحالات اللي
بيتم فيها قهرها وهمم ومجرد ما بتوصل لسن
معين بيتم تزويجها بالذات في الريف او في
الصعيد او في في الاماكن اللي هي البسيطه
فاحنا ما بنتكلمش عن البنت اللي هي بتملك
حوريه الاختيار وبتعمل همم
وبترتبط بزوج سوي بيعملها معامله سوريه
احنا بنتكلم عن غالبيه العظمى للاسف اللي
انا الحاله اللي باحكي لك عنها من القضايا
اللي بتجيء لي ومن اللي انا باشوفه انه
الغالبيه العظمى اتجوزوا لمجرد الجواز
والهرب
صيد نهال هل بالفعل انت مع الرائد بيقول
العزوبيه للمراه ارحم لها من زواج غير
مرتحفي
الزواج هو مؤسسها بتكتمل فيها مشاعر
الاثنين
اثنين بيكملوا بعض الاثنين بياخذوا حياتهم
وبيمضوا بها قدوما الى الافضل والى الاحسن
لو انا محدده ان انا عايزه اسافر في رحله
الماء في وجه الماء وعرفت ان الطياره اللي
انا حركبها دي هتقع او فيها مشاكل او عطل
فنيه اكيد مش حركه بالطياره لكن مش حال
غير رحله هادور على طياره ثانيه تكون افضل
توديني وجهتي احنا المشكله عندنا همم ان
احنا يعني ودي كانت مشكله في في في
الاوقات اللي قبل دي ان الواحد الاختيار
يختار ازاي احنا ما بنتناقش في فكره
الزواج وكلمه عانس وكلمه عازب والكلمات دي
عانس هي فعلا عربي جايه من العنف وهي
الكوبرا هي الامراه او الرجل مش بس المراه
اللي بتوج كبار على عدم الزواج ولكن اعتقد
النهار ده فعل الجبر ما بقاش موجود الجبر
ده حتى في ال- القواعد المجتمعيه لو قلنا
الاقتصاديه او غيره لا النهارده البنت لها
كلمه حتى مع احترامي لزميلتي رشا ولكن
البنت لها كلمه فيها المجتمعات الريفيه
وفي الاكثر تهميشا لا المراه لها كلمه لان
على كل المستويات النهارده المراه لاعب
اساسي في المجال الاقتصادي فتقدر تقول
ليها كلمه هل في بعض السيدات ما لهمش قله
قليله جدا لا يقاس عليها الكل